AS WE JUMP TO OUR NEXT GAME,
FRIDGE NOTES.
WHETHER YOU WORK IN AN OFFICE OR
WITH JUST HAVE ROOMMATES, THE
MOST EFFICIENT MEANS OF
COMMUNICATION IS A WELL-CRAFTED
POST-IT NOTE ON A FRIDGE.
IT CAN MEAN THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN LIFE AND DEATH, OR
HAVING SUFFICIENT HUMMUS FOR
YOUR CRUDITES.
THE SUBREDDIT R/FUNNY TURNED US
ON TO SOME CLEVER REFRIGERATOR
POST-IT NOTES LIKE THIS: MY
TRADER JOE'S GREEN JUICE GREW
LEGS AND WALKED OFF, WHY?
SO COMEDIANS, I WANT YOU TO COME
UP WITH AT MANY POST-IT MESSAGES
THAT YOUWOULD WANT TO LEAVE ON
THE FRIDGE AS YOU CAN IN 60
SECONDS. AND BEGIN!
SETH.
>> IF YOU TAKE SOME SEMEN
SAMPLE, PLEASE REPLACE.
>> CHRIS: OH, YEAH.
>> HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
>> CHRIS: NOW I KNOW HOW THE
POST IT NOTES STUCK TO THE
FRIDGE.
NIKKI GLASER.
>> WHOEVER DRANK MY NAKED JUICE
OWES ME THE VALUE OF $100.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MARK NORMAND.
>> THOSE AREN'T FUDGESICLES,
THOSE ARE MY STOOL SAMPLES,
RALPH.
>> Chris: POINTS.
OH, POOR RALPH.
NIKKI.
>> STOP (BLEEP)ING MY ALMOND
BUTTER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MARK NORMAND.
>> STOP PUTTING QUICHE WITH ME;
THE OTHER APPLIANCES THINK I AM
GAY.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NIKKI.
>> THE JOKE'S ON YOU: IT WAS
BREAST MILK.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
HERZOG.
>> THE CRISPER LIES!
>> Chris: POINTS.
NIKKI GLASER.
>> DOES MY BEN AND JERRY'S LOOK
LIKE IT HAS YOUR NAME ON IT
JERR -- NEVER MIND, YOU CAN HAVE
IT.